cyclone buttser i brought with it heavy
rains strong winds death and destruction
the tropical storm weakened as it moved
across madagascar but not before causing
serious damage
thousands of buildings destroyed or
flooded across the island it's already
southern africa's second biggest cyclone
this year
residents of menongeri the epicenter of
the storm are still waiting for help
our house collapsed we don't know where
to go we have no food we have nowhere to
go all our things were in our house the
children's clothes school supplies
everything was destroyed
we have to help everyone whether they
live on the beach or in the city we
really have to find a solution
the world food program warned the
cyclone destroyed staple crops making a
food shortage crisis in the months to
come almost inevitable we know for sure
that the rice fields and rice crops will
be damaged will be lost
so this is the main uh
main
you know crop for malagasy people is and
they will be seriously affected in their
food security in the next three six
months if we don't do something
immediately and we don't help them to
recover
an estimated 150 000 people have been
affected so far
more than three quarters of madagascar's
28 million people live in poverty aid
workers are expecting the number of
affected people to go up still reeling
from a tropical storm in january which
killed 55 people before the extreme wet
weather communities were coping with
years of such severe drought the u.n
warned it could lead to the world's
first climate change-related famine
the african continent its leaders say is
paying the highest price for climate
change
zain basravi al jazeera